this is the awesome da vinci surgical
system
performing open fruit surgery
stitching up a grape wow
the system is showcasing its sensational
surgical skills on the softest skin
imaginable
the grape surgery is impressive enough
in itself but the grape is actually
inside a bottle
amazing how is this mind-blowing machine
stitching something so small
in such a confined space these robots
are used for keyhole surgery
which as the name implies means going
through a very small space
human hands just aren't equipped to do
that so the surgeon
is actually sitting behind a console
where he can see what's going on on a
high definition screen
and the doctor can even zoom in up to 10
times on that grape skin
the instruments themselves can rotate
with seven degrees of motion that's a
lot
more freedom than a surgeon's hands and
wrists would give them
the best surgeons can be accurate up to
about a hundred micrometers
the davinci robot is accurate to 50
micrometers
so that means that this robot is twice
as accurate as the best human hand
because the robot is so accurate and so
steady it does less damage to the tissue
and the patient can recover faster
and today's patient the good news is
that after a quick recovery this grape
made it back to its bunch